so I did some shopping for the in-laws
as well just some grapes okay guys my
mom has a phobia I'm gonna do a prank on
horses and their banana me from a
juvenile with my clothes had hose enough
I'm afro is picky - the night east
machine or Musashi ice no laces inner
Archie's new millennium yeah yeah the
hilbert aluminum Vania day he won I mean
whole face tansy tansy no meaning mean
mean mean Hakim unhurried mad Hakim in
high-need
what medicine you take concern now is
about the nausea and yes Tommy pens
we're up somewhere exactly the pain is
never getting a medication so I'm gonna
wait for that as well so Kim to get some
not cashew nuts but yeah don't get these
dates these support Israel these metal
dates here King Solomon stay away stay
away from that
they just reversed into this
so guys I'm out today in middle Milan do
some shopping and I've got this I picked
up a bloody basket that's limiting okay
guys my mom has a phobia I'm gonna do a
little prank on horses and their element
she has a phobia yeah she finds this
disgusting you see that much yeah
next time Fido it's very short punchy
shut up about my mom's too funny so she
went to the chicken aisle in middle to
get some chicken and I was just watching
her and she got it and I was like mom
you know and she was like I was ugly I
was like is that what you feeding me
like this huh she's not no no I careful
please Maya is that how many times has
our parents mom or dad needed something
everyone friends girlfriends need you to
do something and don't get it twisted
I'm gonna try to act here like some
superhero need something and I can't be
bothered
yeah and that's wrong you know and I
reflect upon those times we need to
reflect how friends yeah when it's
someone else
we run why because it's about who you
value that's how it is you know I didn't
be in your head you know what you value
and prioritize so if you don't
prioritize summer you're not gonna
breathe
if for example you need to link up with
someone that you're a guy or whatever it
may be a be a business opportunity a job
opportunity if you're missing Sal ah for
that it shows your priority lies there
and this is really sad because Allah is
the one who's given your risk you're
putting us a lot to the side you see in
general to go and get a job Allah is the
one who provides a trophy so here guys
important reminder for us to inshallah
make sure that we are trying our best to
in sha Allah help our month parents they
are you a daughter Jenna never forget
that ok guys so basically I was a bit
hungry so I came to Shepherds Bush
chicken cottage and I was just in the
queue I ordered my food so I've been the
guy so what he did is you can see in a
video yet you can see that he's put
these barriers in place which I like
seats and stuff like that's quite
creative but I was just standing there
and I'll just look into the menu and
he's that brother brother
I was thinking what's he talking about
someone's coming past what's wrong is
that you're coming to cross
I said I'm
flipping nearly 1 2 meter distance but
he said relax yourself so I had some
free time to myself when I fall let me
delete some videos or videos and
pictures for my phone and I came across
this beautiful recitation by was that
yeah yeah enjoy and also when on social
media and for let me see what Faisal and
Moses up to here's what they were up to
or so I don't know opposite assistant is
not excessive okay yes that is no no he
can either be an excessive amount so
it's jealousy is did you her love that
thing can either be an excessive amount
or could be something that is not
excessive not excessive that's it for
example uh something that is completely
excessive and it's not forgiven for
example you want to buy a car key yeah
bike alright what's quite you know buy
Mercedes early Mercedes you wanna buy
Mercedes okay you so you go - you got
some CDs dealership you sign a contract
for a Mercedes car twenty five thousand
pounds it's not contract credit yeah why
not
you don't know anything goes about the
car oh no I need to know the phone
exactly so you need to know the car so
this type of Johana this type of
ignorance is something that it's not
forgiven because you don't know the make
of the car the muzzle of the car you
don't nothing about the Hogsett the
price so is that valid of course of
money so I know that your dad you have
to know the products
all right well my favorite SIM bead my
dad is not feeling well
also my mom's a bit better so I need to
get him he's having a little temperature
calling the black seed it's a good way
of giving Dow as well I told him to
process a black system for anything
except death he was a car with you
arrested Islam you know go to the virus
there's no traffic wardens can park
wherever you like which is a positive
thing yes ceremony come what happens way
better two brothers and sisters and my
reminder for you guys today with what's
going on with the corona virus is to
keep fit the government is told everyone
to come out on this is essential however
they have allowed us to go to the parks
offer a joke as long as you have the
distance and you're not too close to
somebody or someone unless is your
family member keeping fit at this time
is very very important why especially
for those who are suffering with mental
health the first thing that we want to
do when were in depression is not stay
at home but with the current situation
we have no choice but stay at home so
make the most out of it and every now
and then go out for a jog even for the
walk
it would inshallah bring your mood
and remember Manohara even when you're
running